Russia's foreign minister has criticized
the organization for security and
cooperation in Europe as it opens its
annual meeting in Poland without him
Sergey lavrov accused the osce of being
anti-russian after host country Poland
banned him from attending meeting in
Woodshire opened with denunciations of
Russia's war against Ukraine which has
been one of the group's biggest
challenges since it was created nearly
50 years ago as a forum to discuss
security matters within Europe
like correspondent Terry shorts is at
those talks in Poland she told me how
Russia is being discussed in Mr lavrov's
absence
that's right uh the Russia is
represented by its ambassador to the
osce and certainly the issue of Russia's
war on Ukraine absolutely dominated this
meeting of 57 countries here in Poland
uh country after country denounced
moscow's actions its aggression against
Ukraine and pledged more support for
Kiev but foreign minister lavrov may
have been out of sight but he was not
out of mind as he gave a long rambling
press conference at exactly the same
time the meeting was getting underway he
trashed the organization criticized the
Polish chairmanship of it and said that
the osce is basically under control of
the United States but once again the
majority of the countries here the vast
majority are firmly against Russia
there's even discussion of of whether
Russia should be kicked out of the
organization despite there not being a
mechanism to do that so certainly here a
sentiment was uh firmly against Moscow
whatever lavrov may have been saying
there
and the eu's foreign policy Chief Joseph
Burrell has been saying that the plan is
to make Russia pay for the
Reconstruction of Ukraine um how are
they planning to do that
that's right foreign policy Chief
Burrell brought up those issues here at
the osce and said he would be discussing
them with Partners here and there are
some creative ways the EU is looking at
making Russia pay for what is done in
Ukraine as it as it reiterates all the
time uh for example there are some 20
billion euros in assets that have been
frozen assets of oligarchs have been put
on Russia's Blacklist there's also some
300 billion euros of of assets that the
Russian bank has that it can't use right
now and so one of the ways that the EU
is is thinking it could get money from
Russia to Kiev at the moment without any
any other legal mechanisms to do it is
by investing the Russian money and using
the interest to give it to Kiev there
are other ways that it plans to work on
long term to do that and one of them is
of course paying War reparations after
the war is over but at the moment
they're very much looking for practical
ways to get money to Kiev from Moscow
quickly and what else is on the agenda
there at what should presumably it's not
all about Russia and Ukraine
it's not all about Russia and Ukraine
but as I mentioned that's absolutely
dominating the meeting you know uh
speaker after speaker the foreign
ministers are having to to basically
address the questions of whether the
osce is a viable and effective
organization because it operates by
consensus that means that in this case
Russia or one of its allies Belarus or
or any other country on another issue
can block the the organization from
moving forward for example at the moment
Moscow is blocking the the 2024 budget
and blocking the next chairmanship uh
which would be held by Estonia so
there's a lot of talk about about how
the organization can be effective if
it's running on consensus but in in
general the sentiment is that despite
the the difficulties that's undergoing
now there is still value in having 57
countries including Russia uh sit around
the table so so for now there's a lot of
support for the osce in general okay
thank you Terry Terry Schultz at the osc
meeting in Poland